and open hi hi
nice to meet you I'm Thomas nice to meet
you I'm Jupiter what are you two doing
here dating outside our race yeah
I don't know why but that response is
funny yo what are you guys doing here
dating outside a race
if I want to deal with a workout someone
roll up on me and be like hey what are
you doing here I'm like hey betraying my
kind
laughs
hey hey hey what are you doing here
apple with this me I'm kicking it with
the snow bunnies you know what I'm
saying hey what's going on here
disappointing my father yeah yeah
this is a fun way to meet people so I'm
really excited yeah I'm super nervous
but I'm excited for sure
yeah why are you nervous well
I mean no no not at all no not at all
have you ever dated a Latina woman have
you ever spoken to Latino oh I've spoken
to Latino yeah you like churros right
why is this guy like so jumpy yeah
how come you have never dated outside of
your race
um white men just scare me a little I
don't know if it's because it's like the
bias of like white men are the type to
do something crazy or or your little
pink penis is ugly what what she said
white men are the type to do something
crazy
you're Latina Latina
you're crazy she really thinks you crazy
what stereotypes have you heard about my
race when it comes to dating
oh
I don't want to get
canned sometimes when you're at the
grocery store and you're pushing the
cartels uh there's just a certain
I'm not feeling rude I heard like y'all
can be crazy what's wrong with a little
crazy
what's wrong with the little crazy oh
you said it was something wrong with a
little crap
what's wrong with a little crazy
like y'all can be crazy what's wrong
with a little crazy I don't think
there's anything wrong with a little
crazy I think he's just a pushover yeah
I think he's just a question that's why
she laughs is it is she gave him a
little bit of pushback and this [__]
folded like origami
they folded him 10 20 times over yay
are you a picky eater no can you handle
spicy food let's start there I might be
a little wimp when if it's too spicy but
I'ma try it like
yo are you are you a picky eater no can
you handle this dick
that was good that was good how many
black friends do you have
one that's zero if you don't have one
that's a good thing about though I did
because I have one what can I say who's
the one like are you close or is it
co-worker
I mean some people are friends with
their co-workers yeah but some people
use the term friend loosely serenade me
with a song you think someone of my race
would lie
[Music]
that's one of my best songs old school
[__] like Latino [__]
a lot of the young people don't give a
[__] they like to know my boy I used to
play that all the time no they like
b-i-pv hey that's
right
whatever the salsa songs and they play
anything
one who does all of it he got blonde
hair from Puerto Rico and Bob Bob bunny
yeah yeah
[Music]
you mean they all have long hair now yo
they play anything about this game
please do not say
turn that [__] off turn that [__] off
this one comes over from our patreon I
want to give a shout out to Jana bazabas
one of our bazabbers
my man's got my name man that's [__]
his name that's wild bruh but shout outs
to you you've been one of our longtime
patreon supporters if y'all know we take
a lot of recommendations from our
patreon so if you want you can go there
we got over a hundred exclusive videos
right there you can watch as well as
archive stuff that's only available for
people there as well as Early Access and
there's much more to come on the patreon
so if you want to support us in a
different way and get extra ab and
preach content go there and if you
Abba's son you get to this
yeah he's your son he does
shout out to Yen
shout out son I don't really got
anything so I'm gonna take a shot like I
honestly don't really got nothing do you
know who Selena is
we have the Haitian version
huh
tell me two reasons why I should date
you and two reasons why I shouldn't I'm
really really was knowledgeable if
someone were to date me they'd end up
knowing so much about everything yeah so
you sponge for knowledge yeah two I feel
like I'd like I'd push you in life it's
the ambition like every time I've dated
someone like they're here and then as
soon as they stop dating me they're like
here they're way up there yeah maybe
you're not pushing them maybe them
getting away from you realize like oh
this [__] anchor and weight is just
gone Hey listen if every time your ex
leave all of a sudden they like 10K
richer than [__] I want to date you too
can you imagine that some girl some
girl's [__] and breakup cured your
unemployment
that's not cheating if I wasn't with
your ass you have secrets and your
cousin told me that logical thinking is
just something that you laugh what you
even mad for looking like a stick in
your [__] he's like he's not feeling
this at all
the [__] is this why are you pointing at
me baby let's do this in private so I
don't get embarrassed
and then I don't remember the rest yeah
I thought she just sorry you know what I
thought she said I thought she just sang
some Chinese propaganda and I was like
[__] are you serious right now
I thought she was just like miles yeah
man never happened
just like you guys hugers go to the camp
like just so crazy you know
tell me the mostest thing you've ever
done or take a shot
um
ain't nobody gonna say that except white
boy
no he definitely won't
folded like origami this dude will show
his butthole on camera before he says
what the [__] racing [__] he gonna say
fair you might be like ooh see this
butthole kind of brown like Mexicans
like I don't know you might
face or anything like that I've never
done blackface
being along to like Doja cat count what
I don't know trying I'm reaching here if
you're not saying the n word I have
never said the n-word and I stand by
that you stand by that okay
hey weirdly enough I think she's really
into him I'm not sure how he I think
he's open to it I think those two got
the most chemistry even though it may
not look like yeah I think they do so
when I was 15 I was getting by someone
in order to stop getting by that person
I decided to befriend him right and so
that meant doing and saying the things
that he was saying and one of those
things was like the n-word with the hard
R so I was just hella saying that
without any regard any regard to it
exactly and I feel a lot of Shame about
that I thought something I would never
do thank you for sharing that thank you
for sharing that with me you're canceled
yes you are yes you are what's your
Twitter where do you work we're gonna
find out you little [__] [__]
what did you say when you were 14 not
you you're getting fired with a hard ER
it's Ed [__] you
between the two of us who is hotter oh
that's easy you obviously yeah I don't
think so I think we're like in I love
that [__] I love that [__]
um who do you think is hotter you are oh
my God I don't think so [__] nobody
asked you
you're hot take that [__] and go when I
say that you're hot it has nothing to do
about what you think I think you hot
shut the [__] up take my my compliment
and leave I don't think so
I don't give a [__] she'd be nice
because like she understands that
amazing what he's saying oh I'm less
attractive than you are and the way
she's seen it she's like no we're
equally attracted
some chemistry
I'm just saying if I give you a
compliment and you come around with oh I
don't think I don't care just know just
know I don't give a [__] I don't know if
you notice
let my Curry Queen do everything
[__] all that [__] all right listen all
right no if I give you a compliment you
shut the [__] up you take that [__]
about that get that Korean Fried Chicken
up there's a bunch of Koreans being like
why is he saying like that why is he
saying like a [__] robot why are you
baby and why are you saying like that
Henson
hey hey and there's a bunch of
uncultured people like what the [__] is
a bibimbap and you need to eat some
Korean yeah okay do you say it like that
no but that's how I say it every time
yeah I don't care that's like 75 of the
reason why I want to go to Korea I just
want to walk in not speak any Korean go
baby
you know you can stop
[Applause]
around my neck
instead of Dirty Pop yeah
hey man this is one of the dumbest
bricks let's go honestly you have
beautiful eyes thank you I appreciate it
so I would say you because I have poop
color eyes I have brown no but that's
but you're so um but you're so pretty
what that's not really no that really
surprises me like oh my gosh I will say
me to be honest but that's just that's
my opinion okay you said yourself I'm
gonna say myself then all right okay we
like confident people
what's the kinkiest thing that you have
ever done I remember one time I was
kissing this guy and like he bit my lip
and he made me bleed and I got so turned
on by it and you're afraid of white boys
I had a girl dig her nails so hard into
my back it started to bleed I was like
what the [__] are you doing it's like
you don't like that I'm like [__] you
left scars
Straight Out of The Lion King why would
I like that
you left scores this is the second time
we [__] it I gotta live with that
permanently my [__] I remember I'm I
remember one day one day girls be asking
what are these on your back I'm like
shut up don't ask
I remember one day we were all doing
Capoeira right it was me my girl my
sister
outside right and then I take my shirt
off and you know I'm about to go in the
circle my sister's like oh [__] oh my
God what happened to your back and I
just went like this
hmm
and my girl went like oh [__] if you are
feeling it let's seal this day with a
kiss
I don't know if I'm feeling it I don't
know if I'm feeling it I told you I told
y'all but the other two they definitely
gonna make out yeah
hey hey hey hey hey I want to tell you
what did I tell you you know what the
thing is he probably just thinking man
just do that rap [__] in private while
we [__] or something man listen it's
bad enough to be seen with a snow bunny
but you ain't gotta be rapping what I
look like playing you rap in front of me
sounding crazy yeah we're having [__]
you can rap just do it
Pokemon
a kiss I have so much lipstick on yo
let's save it for the next day save it
for the next day okay that sounds good
so would you two go on another date yes
yeah all right then
wow
[Laughter]
look at the giggling
go on they give you different oh yeah
wow
okay
Giggles all right well there you guys
have it you know they definitely gonna
be [__] so good for them yeah live
your life she was definitely giving the
we [__] uh he was definitely going
for that I'm trying to get some [__]
vodka I'm mad at it live your life God
damn it [__] yeah I mean listen white
women out there just just don't wrap
around us and you gonna be all right
just don't rap that we gonna be good
still J Cole's my favorite keep it to
yourself play the song just don't rapper
please I don't want I just had some
flashbacks this week some things same
thing so that's awesome don't do it I
think that's pretty much it and anything
else no let us know what you guys think
of the comments below and don't forget
the patreon if you guys want to submit
videos to us you guys want us to check
them out go to our patreon sub right
there send it to us we always like in
our submissions
we got some other things exclusive